hey guys in this video I'm going to give
you five important reasons why you need
to join a men's bible study
group the first reason is because
Proverbs 27:17 says iron sharpens iron
and one man sharpens another you know we
are in this world but we're not part of
this world and so even though there's a
lot of darkness in this world the best
friends that you can make are those who
take their relationship with god
seriously Godly men who you can trust
with your life men who inspire you and
motivate you to become better men who
are there to be a friend who listens
when things are tough and a brother who
holds you accountable for when you act
up or make mistakes a Bible study group
for men is an ideal place where you can
meet other brothers in Christ men who
are serious with God that is the place
where where you can also meet a good
friend maybe even a best
friend someone that you can call a
brother a brother for a life that will
help you to walk this temporary world
that's full of Darkness but to walk it
the right way with Christ as your focus
point is it not interesting that when
Jesus sent out the disciples he sent
them out two by two read it with me Luke
10:1 after this the Lord appointed 72
others and send them on ahead of him two
by two into every town and place where
he himself was about to go you know I
personally have a handful of men that I
trust fully that I can go to and ask for
advice Godly men that I know are serious
with God and when I ask them to pray for
me or talk about certain issues then I
know they really care about me and have
the best of intentions for me and they
will go to God and pray with me and for
me even when I'm not talking to them if
you don't have men like that in your
life
Brothers then pray to God ask him to
send you men that you can trust that you
can build a strong relationship with
moving forward until the day you die and
then start joining a men's bible study
group this week if you
can
the second reason is God wants us to
have fellowship with other believers you
know I've heard some men say well I
don't want to go to church because
church it's just full of fake people
well first of all the church is not a
place for people who are perfect you
will find Sinners there because all of
us are sinners it is a place for broken
people who know they need God
desperately people like you you and me
we all have that sinful nature in us and
we will have it until the day we
die no one is perfect and so when you go
to church don't expect to find perfect
people you will find unbelievers there
you'll also find people who are new
Christians babies in Christ and then you
will also find other people who are
mature Christians and even they still
make
mistakes because all of us still have
that sinful fleshly nature in us we go
to church for different
reasons and so the first thing is we go
to church for God to learn to grow
together that's why we go so instead of
judging other people look at the log in
your own eye first before you judge
other people because Christ came for
Sinners not for those people who think
they're perfect the second reason you go
to church is not just so that you can
get fed the whole time with spiritual
milk so that you can just grow and grow
and grow and you're just sitting there
and becoming fat spiritually fat
no it's also there the church because
you need to go and help people you need
to contribute it's not just about you
and third the church is not the
building the church is where brothers
and sisters come together in Christ to
worship God that's a church so that
means a Bible study group group is also
the Church of God and then
four God tells us to go to church it is
not something that we can decide it is
what scripture says so you need to
decide do you want to listen to your
fleshly sinful nature that tells you I
don't want to go to church or to God
that says go Hebrews 10 verse 24 and let
us consider how to stir up one another
to love and good good works not
neglecting to meet together as is the
habit of some but encouraging one
another and all the more as you see the
day Drawing
Near the third reason why you need to go
to a men's bible study is because men
are different right women are different
men talk about different things and
there are things that you need to hear
from other men that's grounded in
scripture like how to be a good father
how to be a good husband how to be a
good man according to the Bible 1
Corinthians 16:13 says Be watchful stand
firm in the faith act like men be strong
let all that you do be done in love you
know men can be very childish I'm
talking about men who are not reborn
Christians their way of thinking is
still worldly you know especially if you
have a group of men and their egos and
they just puffed up and you you
see but what you learn when you join a
men's bible study is to change your way
of thinking living and acting according
to God's word and so you leave those
childish things behind 1 Corinthians
13:1 when I was a child I spoke like a
child I thought like a child I reasoned
like a child when I became a man I gave
up childish
ways you know there's something
beautiful and special about men coming
together to pray together read scripture
together and worship God you know it is
it I keep on thinking about certain men
like David you know men who are there
who say Here I Am Lord change me take
out everything that is not right men who
are serious with God when they come
together and they pray for each other
they worship God that is special and if
you join a group like that you will
become a stronger man and grow in Christ
you'll become a mature man mature reborn
Christian the fourth reason is you can
learn from good Role Models there are
many older men that I grew to respect
and admire men who are spiritually
mature and who already walked the life I
now walk carrying with them an immense
amount of experience that I learn from
so this is where you get mentors role
models that you can learn from and we
need to learn from these kind of people
that already walked most of the path the
Journey of
sanctification that you are walking on
now and still going to walk on they went
through many challenges
they're almost done with their Journey
the next step for them is Almost Heaven
these are people who are over 60 70 80
years old so they completed most of
their race already victoriously learning
how to overcome challenges through
biblical principles values and also
commands things that we have to do so
they learn not just to be hearers of the
word but to be doers and we also need to
learn from their mistakes just like we
can learn from the mistakes of the
nation of
Israel 1 Corinthians 10:6 now these
things took place as examples for us
that we might not desire evil as they
did do not be idolators as some of them
were as it is written the people sat
down to eat and drink and Rose up to
play we must not indulge in sexual
immorality as some of them did and
23,000 fell in a single day we must not
put Christ to the test as some of them
did and were destroyed by serpents nor
Grumble as some of them did and were
destroyed by the Destroyer now listen to
this verse 11 now these things happened
to them as an example but they were
written down for our instruction on whom
the end of the ages has
come the fifth reason is identity
purpose and growth you will grow
spiritually a lot faster in am men's
bible study compared to being alone
through this time you will also feel
like you're part of God's family you
have purpose and you also find your
identity as a man in Christ Ephesians
2:10 for we are his worksmanship created
in Christ Jesus for good works which God
prepared beforehand that we should walk
in them now if you're still looking for
a men's bible study group remember you
can also create your own right and if
you're already in a men's bible study
group and you're looking for a
devotional something to work through a
study
guide then get bold Pursuit a 90-day
devotional for men seeking the heart of
God I wrote this specifically for men
I'll add all the details for you in the
video description down below with also
the study group question
you can also get it on my website dlm
christianlifestyle.com or bold pursued
book.com now just so you know what this
book is all about I wrote this book for
men to bring them back to scripture so
that they can become true men of God and
pursue god with everything in them let
me read some of the backover here for
you you could pursue a lot of things in
life money relationships power but only
one Pursuit brings satisfaction on Earth
because only one Pursuit matters for
eternity becoming a true man of God I
think about men like David you know who
took their relationship with God
seriously who prayed and said God search
my heart and take out everything that is
not
right and God looked at David and he
called David a man after my own heart
you know we can have that same
relationship with God
today the action oriented teachings in
bold Pursuit will Challenge and equip
you to pursue God above all else in your
daily
life as you dig deep into God's word
you'll experience the Fulfillment of
making your relationship with Jesus your
greatest priority through each day's
straightforward devotional reading
packed with powerful biblical insights
you'll explore how to worship God in
spirit and in truth what it means to
engage in spiritual battle what sin is
and isn't and why it matters where to
find hope when you're feeling
hopeless practical ways to overcome
destructive habits and
addictions and how to make Bible study
and prayer an integrated part of your
life each daily reading in bold Pursuit
combines a Bible passage with a short
devotional that speaks to the real
issues men face at work and home prayer
prompts reflection questions and action
items bring Focus to each day in an age
of distraction and busyness Every Man's
true calling Remains the
Same to walk with the God who created
you for great things and find the
meaning and purpose your soul
craves I talk a lot in this book book
about the difference between acting
living in the spirit and not in the
flesh and what it means to truly come to
that place where you fully surrender to
Christ you know Jesus asked Peter in
John
21:15 Simon son of John do you love me
more than
these in verse 16 he said to him a
second time Simon son of John do you
love me in verse 17 he said to him the
third time Simon son of John do you love
me you know you've probably heard this a
lot by now that God is love and he loves
you and he does it's true but do you
love him do you love Jesus with
everything that is in
you this
book let you focus on the right things
your relationship with
Jesus and so check it out when you have
some time and if you are serious about
your relationship with God watch these
videos here remember to subscribe and
I'll see you there and always remember
life is short so don't waste
yours bye